hi I'm Ella Gregorek a developer
advocate and web performance engineer at
Google which is to say I like to make
things fast and I'm Cameron Pittman I'm
a course developer here at Udacity I'm
pretty new to web development which
means that I've made a few pages in the
past but I've never optimized any of
them for speed developing and great
website requires that you understand
your users and what they want to achieve
but also how the browser works such that
you can build a fast and great
experience right you know I recently ran
my page through PageSpeed insights and I
well my score was pretty low and I got
some suggestions I didn't quite
understand like for instance how do I
remove render blocking JavaScript and
what are asynchronous scripts you know
those are great questions and you're
definitely not the only one both of the
optimizations that you've asked about
have to do with critical rendering path
which is the sequence of steps that the
browser goes through to render the page
and I think a lot of us take it for
granted that the browser does all the
work but once you understand how the
browser constructs Dom the CSS object
model layout and paint you can reliably
build pages that are rendered in less
than one second Wow one second that is
awesome I would love to have all my
pages render in less than a second what
do I need to get started well to start
how about an hour of your time we're
going to take a ground-up view of how
the browser constructs a page and once
you know that I think you'll be in great
shape to answer your own questions about
how to optimize your page all right so
let's do it
and actually one more thing before we
get started I want you to write down
some thoughts about what you want to get
out of this course and what you would
like to learn okay